i know i'm a little [__] up a little
crazy but what do you want you know
[Music]
peanut butter caitlin
[__] all this [__] weird [__]
that's going on
but it's friday night look at you
[__] looking handsome tonight
it's a date night tonight huh tonight
you've been waiting on a [__] week
for tonight like since wednesday we're
like we want to see joey but [__] that
i'm gonna give mom a stabbing
old school i'm gonna take her back i'm
gonna [__] dose the kids with
benadryl
and i'm gonna give an old-school dick
like we used in the car taco bell when
we were kids and [__]
but nobody [__] the taco bell in the
back what kind of people are you what's
wrong with your people
i wasn't sexually active i was never
into that [__] i'm over
i'm bad and i'm bad at sex like i'm
[__] awful
i've always come in a minute a minute
and a half if i like relax my legs and
remember
[__] but i've always been a bad piece of
ass that's why i can never be a pervert
i come quick like i don't
i have friends i [__] this chick's
[__] up last week you should have seen
it i killed it the [__] was tapping out
i've never [__] up a woman's [__] in
my life
the [__] looks the same as the end this
is in the beginning you understand
i gotta pull the hair to [__] it up a
little bit
it's like when you go to a restaurant
you don't eat the bread you still break
it in half right or wrong
you don't want them to give it out to
somebody else you got to break that
[__] now
i was never a good looking guy like that
that orgs that get invited to
sexual things and then i you know i did
the rut but you finger somebody when
you're 15
you suck a tit all right
and especially like when we grew up in
the east coast we got to do all that
[__] in the cold
you gotta suck a tit behind the church
in the cold weather she's like the
lookout hurry up it's cold
nobody knows what it's like to suck
technical dog
because we had nowhere to take him you
had no driver's license right you
couldn't be grandma's always
at home watching the [__] door while
you would take her to the basement and
make out leave the [__] door open